this is the room where i spent
quite a few months melissa has mixed
feelings about being here
it's both a place of hurt and healing
and not always in equal measure i
definitely remember lying
on that bed every single night and just
wishing i was at home
in my own bed with my own family
and not having to dread waking up the
next morning
she's a patient on this ward for
children and adolescents and she's being
treated for the eating disorder
anorexia nervosa everyone around you
just wants you to be safe and wants to
help but
you really that is the last thing in
that moment that you want
what are the pressures that make things
more difficult for you do you think
um although i do love
being in college i think that's
definitely a big big pressure
um the same with like
friends and peer groups i think although
that is a good thing i think it is still
another big pressure
it's not the thing to sort of perform to
i suppose
and so the paradox of that is the things
that you actually like
are on the other side of the coin the
things that you actually hate at the
same time
yeah definitely eating disorder
referrals
have doubled during the pandemic and
alongside the care
and compassion here there is a stark
reality
that nurses often have to feed patients
via a tube
just to keep them alive i think it's
genuinely up there with one of the worst
things i've ever had to go through
and physically it's such an awful
feeling
and then obviously as well it's
it's really horrible just having that
sort of happening to you
and you know at the same time that you
can't control it or stop
it um
and i think it gets to a point where you
i think i can definitely remember
sitting there having that
having that done to me and thinking like
how did it actually get to this
it's a very very cruel illness to see
your daughter your young daughter
as a child as she was she still is a
child but as a young child
sobbing her heart out because she knows
she's got to eat that meal
and you're sitting there
sort of forcing her into it
and it's horrible sorry it's really
horrible you know she's got to do it
you've got to make her do it you're
making her do something
that is really really awful for her
and you're doing it for all the right
reasons and i think deep down she knows
that
but it's utterly heartbreaking to say
it really is
do you think that they saved your life
in this room
i think yeah looking back on it now i
think definitely
um yeah i think there definitely are
negatives and drawbacks to it but
i think it it does save lives it
it is really important and i've met some
amazing people along the way
um and i don't want that to go unmissed
along
alongside it do you want to get better
i think in principle i do
but i think it's putting that into
action that i struggle with
so for me it feels like a happy ending
for you
because i've journeyed through since
your time here
there is hope here melissa is being
discharged
which means she can go home but the
family have been here before
so there's always that sort of worry at
the back of my mind
as to how are we going to to manage this
will it
you know will this be the time she does
manage to stay out
and i was looking through some work that
you completed for me and
and i kind of talked a bit about how
home is so
lovely and safe for you that makes
me feel happy that this charge has come
and
you're going
[Applause]
okay thank you thanks a lot bye
for melissa this is a new start and
everyone here hopes
she can continue to get better but the
pandemic has revealed that many more
youngsters
will need this kind of treatment and
sadly their journey
is just beginning nick martin sky news
you